so after achieving quite a lot of
success with the TV media your fashion
business what made you decide you wanted
to sort of transition over into the
property side of things so I always
wanted to find a way that I could have
another strand of what I'm doing that
would give me that security and make me
bulletproof and for me that was property
over 100 Grand bro on one little
anyone that I speak to I'll sing You
Praises the fact that they've lost that
piece of paper that could have cost them
50 Grand estate agents are ringing me
constantly saying oh Jordan when's the
house ready people have got money and
people are spending money it just might
be in a different mindset your knowledge
grows with your bank what's addictive
about property to me and what I love
about it is because you can actually be
really creative I'm not going to put my
financial hands in the hands of a sister
so many people are scared of buying now
there's less competitions you're
actually getting better deals now if a
good deal is a good deal anytime's a
good time
Jordan Haynes hello pleasure man to sit
down with you and to pick your brain on
property and what you've done because
what you've achieved on the property
side over the last two years has been
amazing but also I've been watching you
for Years bro I've been watching you
doing TV star interviews with crept and
Conan who have obviously also been
working with you're a bit of a star so
why don't you give a little introduction
to your background and then we can just
talk property man because that's what I
want to do yeah so I started probably
six years ago as a model in Manchester
and prior to that I was actually working
in financial services
um and kind of got like headhunted to be
a model kind of like left out and took a
chance to try and make that work that
became successful
um and then I got the opportunity to go
on a TV show did that and I feel like
that gave me a lot of exposure like put
me out to the world and then from that I
feel like I had to really work hard to
fine-tune where I wanted to go and
that's what I've been working on in the
past three years and I've really kind of
carved a career for myself in high
fashion really which is a crazy thing to
say because it's someone that I've
always worked towards but it's kind of
like come into reality now and
everything you do is in the spotlight so
every time you buy a property or
something like it's often in the media
people are talking about it yeah yeah
and now it's I think it's the first time
you've ever sat down and done like a
full exclusive interview of exactly what
you've done what you're doing so after
achieving quite a lot of success with
the TV media your fashion business how
did you decide and what made you decide
you wanted to sort of transition over
into the property side of things and
start buying houses yeah how did that
happen and when was that yeah for me
I've always tried to compare myself to
people who are at the highest level so I
looked at all my favorite high
performance celebrities and try to
figure out what the denominator was
between them all achieving success over
a long period of time and that
denominator was multiple businesses
Conor McGregor perfect example he's a
UFC fighter he opened his Whiskey
Business he's got McGregor fast where he
does his strength and conditioning
um he's got a pub chain now and so many
different businesses and what's he not
done for the past three four years he
hasn't fought because he's got all these
other businesses that are working hard
for him so in my head when I started to
achieve success
I think you deluded if you think that
you can Master one thing and that's the
one thing you'll do for the rest of your
Lifeline not everyone's Drake yeah I
mean you can't be on top of your game in
one area for 15 years so I always wanted
to find a way that I could have another
strand of what I'm doing
that would give me that security and
make me bulletproof for the rest of my
life and for me that was property
because you know I would see life
actually like I see life like a
department store like let's see if I'm
Harrod's right I've got so many
different departments skincare clothes
shoes and I sell the most shoes ever
that's what makes me as Harrods
successful but then for instance for 3 6
12 months
I can't get any stock to sell shoes if
I've not got my skincare popping off
right then when I can't sell shoes I'm
not making money so for me it's Jordan
Haynes I know that there's a lifespan of
what I'm going to be doing for so long I
want to set something up that is going
to make me bulletproof in the long term
because yeah and I think that takes
financial literacy to do it now it makes
a lot of sense and I think you know I I
coach a lot of like footballers and
stuff and I think they're super smart
because it's so easy as a young person
that's making loads of money it's
getting loads of attention to just think
oh this is gonna happen forever and but
actually saying you know what let me
think about building something that will
last a lifetime and I think property as
well you can't beat it no one's going to
take it away it's going to outlive us
both I think for me as well it's just
surrounding myself with people like
yourself like loads of different people
around the world that were so focused on
financial literacy yeah and learning
things that schools don't teach you yeah
that three years ago I didn't have
anything I didn't have any savings
because that's the life I was living I
started to feel guilty for the way that
I was living my life and the
responsibility that I wasn't putting on
myself to educate myself and put myself
in in environments and situations where
um can learn from people that are high
performing in whatever they're doing so
when I started to do that
um I just really wanted to delve into it
and really start to ask questions yeah
rather than just wonder I want to get
into property but so I think that the
biggest thought in my head was I need to
just start
um but not be worried about the process
in how it will be hard do you know yeah
yeah yeah 100 and it's interesting as
well because when I remember when we had
a one-on-one VIP crash course for you
yeah or well we did like honestly that
the few moments of my life what I'll
remember but that's one of them where I
got off the phone I was like life's
gonna be different now do you know what
I mean yeah I thank you so much for that
that's why like I'm literally anyone
that I speak to I've seen You Praises
because you took the time out you didn't
even need to do that and I'll remember
that forever bro honestly I appreciate
that man and you know what though seeing
not just your portfolio growth because
that's amazing but also now me and you
bounce ideas off each other oh
from from being me explaining stuff and
teaching them and that but also actually
doing it like your knowledge your
knowledge grows with your bank I kind of
feel like yeah if you want your bank to
grow big you've got to grow big yourself
you've got to grow your brain invest in
yourself first and then your portfolio I
think I've been doing it two years now I
think the one thing that I've learned in
the past probably is six to eight months
is being creative with it I have really
learned how to be creative in deals and
not just see a house started because
just got the opportunity to put a bit of
value on it and then sell it like for
instance I've just bought um a property
in Manchester and it's a big Corner plot
semi-detached house and it's got so much
land with it and I noticed that there's
a little bit of land next to it and then
I found out that the next door neighbor
owns that land so what I'm trying to do
is buy that land Nick a bit off my land
because it's got way too much back
garden and then build two houses on the
land next to it yeah whereas a year ago
18 months ago I wouldn't even thought
that but that makes the deal so much
more attractive so that's what's
addictive about property to me and what
I love about it is because you can
actually be really creative and I get as
much as a buzz from it as I do when I'm
walking the catwalk in Milan do you know
what I mean yeah so that's how I know
that the industry's for me and and I
really like the contrast and I really
like where I can go with it and you can
really mold
into whatever you're doing and also I
came from a professional background
anyway so these like professional
conversations that I was having I
enjoyed anyway so like just working in
fashion obviously I love it but I'm kind
of missed that so it's nice that I can
do this now build something for the
future and then you know in in 10 20
years when Jordan Haynes isn't wearing a
bomber from Rick Owens anymore I can
work in property you know so let's talk
first deal yeah because that made you
about over 100 Grand profit yeah yeah
right over 100 Grand bro on one little
deal and the thing is that deal it just
looked like a normal house yeah it was
run down talk me through your first deal
what was the strategy what were the
figures so first deal was somebody's
hatched house in Manchester up and
coming area like really easy Network to
Town Center which already made it
attractive for me
um so it's perfect for a family who
maybe mum and dad lived worked in town
but kids you know wanted a nice area
where they could go to school Etc so I
liked the area first and foremost it was
a probate so it got inherited by the
kids of the grandma mahoud passed away
so naturally it was super super run down
I don't think it had been done up for
like 30 years or so what the nice thing
about it was is it had a nice big back
garden and also I knew the area was like
perfect for families and I looked on the
street as well and I could see that a
few people on the street have done
extensions maybe it was a side extension
above the garage or a back extension
um so the price of it just made complete
sense once I pinned the price of the one
that I bought to what they were in the
area yeah so we got it for 107 180k and
then last minute we managed to get it
down to 170 I remember very well because
I negotiated for 180 yeah yeah and then
the last minute you were like hey your
negotiation skills were good Samuel but
I got it down another 10.
I'm just thinking I hope it doesn't fall
through no I hope you're not so pushing
it yeah um and what was it about that
property as well because if I remember
rightly I was doing a Financial Freedom
challenge that week and um you know I
was helping Lawton who lives in
Manchester to find a bunch of deals and
then we were trying to sell deals and I
said to him right we need to contact
some investors so we will call investors
selling deals and at the same time you
were messaging me saying I'm looking for
a deal you got anything yeah yeah you
came down in person I did I think we
showed you from memory two or three
houses three three houses three houses
and then there and then within the space
of about two hours yeah you you decided
that's the one I want that's the one I
buy we ship hands we got an agreement in
place and I think that's another thing a
lot of people there's such slow decision
makers yeah they'll be like oh man I
speak to so many people to tell me I
want a house I want a house I want a
house can you get me something I'll
sauce them it for them and then they'll
be like well let me speak to my lawyer
yeah and let me but if you speak to your
lawyer or your financial advisor they're
always going to tell you oh it's a bit
risky yeah sometimes you've got to think
actually I'm not going to put my
financial hands in the hands of a
solicitor who's making 60 Grand a year
no for sure for sure I think for me like
when I walk in one that I know that I
want I make the decision like that and
I'm ready to go I've got you know what's
been nice as well and I think is most
important thing what I'll tell anyone
getting into property build your team
build a solid foundation of a team
around you in terms of solicitors
mortgage advisors building control
Engineers Builders electricians plumbers
everyone that you need so that when an
opportunity does arrive you can bam jump
straight on it and that's what I've done
so I think even from that first deal
when I knew straight away that I wanted
it I took that into every deal that I've
done yeah and so then when we got in
there obviously we stripped everything
back and realized that we pretty much
the only thing we kept about that
property was the bricks well we had to
rip everything out I can't lie bro I was
a bit worried because of how much you
were spending
you bought the house for 170 which is a
banging price banging prices but you
were spent because you're like a fashion
designer I could see what you were
spending on it yeah and I was thinking
if he spends too much yeah it's worrying
and it doesn't make profit yeah it's
gonna make me look crap because then
Jordan's gonna be like oh I sourced a
deal from Samuel Leeds and I made three
grand profit thanks mate
I was worried because you were spending
big bro yeah and you were also as well
you were very Hands-On you were there
regularly you were overseeing the team
you weren't just like oh I'm just gonna
just rely on the builders and rely on
everybody to saw it you were Hands-On so
you bought it for 170 how much did you
end up in total how much did you end up
spending to make it look like you did at
the end we spent about
150 on it damn spent 150 Grand on it
which was a full rip out we put a three
meter extension on the back which turned
into the kitchen dining open plan area
big bifolds on back obviously new
windows and doors new roof new plaster
new floors kitchen bathrooms that was
everything 150k and the thing is for me
my strategy with property is like my
strategy so far anyway when I'm buying
houses when I'm buying properties I
really want to create an environment
that is like as high-end as it can be so
I'm really hitting that top end of the
spectrum because I basically I buy in
areas in Manchester that are up and
coming so in Manchester you've got your
areas like hail Altrincham older The
Edge which are like it's some beautiful
beautiful area but the house prices are
like really really expensive yeah what I
do is buy properties in areas that are a
bit more up and coming but create them
high value properties so the people who
hire earners that have big families can
move into my house so I put a beautiful
like interior in it and it's still a
really nice area but they're not paying
the high the high costs that you do in
them other areas and the strategies work
myself that wouldn't work if you were in
a cheap part of Manchester where the
ceiling prices are only 250 Grand
exactly it wouldn't work because if you
start spending a fortune because you
were lit bro man you were you were
spending on the house as if it was your
house yeah an island kitchen you
extended the whole house made it bigger
and the interesting thing is I think
that the reason we got that house so
cheap because in the street they're all
saying for like 400. I think the reason
we got it for so cheap was because of
the structural problems because it was
like wobbly bro yeah they said that
they'd underpinned it but they didn't
have the certificates all the proof and
we used that to our advantage to really
negotiating cheap and the actual
structural aspect of the house fixing
that and underpinning it stuff yeah
didn't cost that much well the thing is
it didn't actually need underpinning so
they'd basically underpinned it lost the
paperwork yeah so obviously I said it's
not been underpinned but then when my
Builder came in and I bought it it had
been underpin they just lost the
paperwork so that should is the fact
that they'd lost that piece of paper
that could have cost them 50 Grand yeah
exactly so what did you have to do
structurally to the house or was it
nothing literally just level the floors
I think it was already did you have to
get presumably a structure engineer to
come out yeah yeah we had a building
control instructional Engineers come out
and check it every step of the way but
it was already underpinned floors had
only been leveled in one room so since
the underpinned it they hadn't sorted
the floors out so that's why it felt
wobbly once we leveled the floors which
cost I don't know man like ten thousand
right it was all good so when people
were coming around to view it they're
saying it's wobbly it's apparently been
underpinned but there's no proof no one
wanted to touch it they're worried that
it might cost you know 50 Grand but we I
remember we took out um we brought a
stuck to engineer didn't we yeah and he
was just like it's all right yeah yeah
we're gonna be all right with this one
but you still spent a freaking Fortune
yeah and the thing is that is the risk
because until you actually buy it you
can't go into the floorboards and look
exactly what the problem is yeah so
there's the risk right that was the like
400 000 potential to 170 Grand buying
price because I obviously did take the
risk on yeah the other day I'm young
yeah I mean yes I'm in a position where
I want to take risk and that's why you
make the most money were you scared were
you scared behind that first one because
I do remember yeah when you were saying
to me what's the worst case yeah what's
the lowest value and I said look it
ain't gonna come in less than 390
absolutely worse guys even if the market
drops yeah yeah well how did you feel
going from a fashion designer media
Personality yeah to put in a huge sum of
money yeah into a property with no
experience in property like what was the
Motions going on there because I knew it
was like I just used my brain I knew
that it was so under the market value I
wasn't worried because I know at the
very least every single pound that I put
into it to do the renovation and the
development I was gonna get back it was
just a question of how much profit am I
going to make right that's how I felt so
I was pretty relaxed but I've not done
it before so it was a lot of work
especially when I'm trying to thrive in
my day job and what I'm doing is Jordan
Haynes like it was hard in terms of like
managing my time Etc but in terms of
like how worried it was I wasn't worried
at all because it ended out like even if
I would have lost some of it I mean I
would have took what I learned from it
to go on to another song and you learn
loads on it so what's the what is the
value come in at the end so you bought
it for 170. you spent 150 you say so in
total that's what like 3 20 yeah and
then what's the three what did the value
come out at the end uh four three five
so 115 grams or something like that yeah
yeah cleaned 100 Grand Over clean clean
what did you think when the valuation
came in
so happy I was so happy and also it was
really encouraging to know that the
strategy that I adopted by going for
that high-end value and like making the
house the absolute best it can be based
on how much land was available yeah
really spurred me on so I wanted to do
it again and then I bought a bungalow
with so much more potential I'm still
building it right now but it's about to
um it's about to be finished and may
it's going to be amazing I bought a two
bed Bungalow again right near Manchester
Airport
um it's going to be a five slash six
bedroom multi-generational house what uh
what did you pay for it I paid 240 for
it and what do you think the end value
would be
good numbers
will you make more than 100 Grand yeah
way more that's awesome yeah wait and
you've got a third you know yes I've got
a third yeah which also a bungalow and
you own that now it's completed yeah
yeah that's completed the renovation is
going to be done the same time as this
of one because what I did was because
the second bundle that I bought because
that's going to be huge I had to apply
for plan of permission and it took like
eight months bro it took so long so what
I did in the meantime I bought another
Bungalow close by I only wanted to put a
couple Dormers in upstairs so I knew
that the planet finisher would get
approved quickly and I could have my
Builder working simultaneously on them
both just to increase my productivity
yeah and so that one's going to be done
soon but now planning's approved on the
first Bungalow and they're both going to
be done some other time so you're
building a bit of an Empire here yeah
what are you doing with the properties
then because are you
um and how did you come to the decision
to do this are you selling at the end or
are you keeping so the first one a
refinanced purely for Speed because I
had the second Bungalow and the third
Bungalow that I needed to fund the
developments for yeah but I'm about to
put that on the market and then the
Bungalows I want to flip man you want to
yeah chunks of cash yeah but what's
really encouraging is that the estate
agents are ringing me concerts saying oh
Jordan when's the house ready when's the
house ready so as although like there's
so much hurray on what's going on in the
market right now and there's not as much
competition which I've experienced from
another house that I've just bought
people are definitely buying houses
because what you've got to understand is
as much as cost of living is coming up
and people can't afford houses you've
got people that are downsizing yeah
bigger houses to small houses so I feel
like there's so much stigma on our
financials are so bad in the country
right now but people have got money and
people are spending money it just might
be in a different mindset so do you
think now in 2023 you obviously studied
it a lot you're doing it so you think
it's a good time to be buying houses
cheap doing them up and flipping them or
do you think that because of the markets
changing and it's a little people are
not buying as much you think it's a bad
time to get into it is it a good time I
think that if a good deal is a good deal
anytime's a good time yeah and also like
I bought a house on auction the other
day there was four people I was bidding
against I got the house for so cheap so
if there's less competition means you
can get a better deal on a house yeah
plus this is how our view property is
like people saying don't buy weights
until it goes down but the thing is if
you buy property right now yeah and the
value does go down the overall
trajectory of the property property
business in the property industry over
10 years span has gone up so even if you
bought a house and it dipped you just
keep hold of it until it goes up and
surpasses what it's dipped by and then
you're going to be in profit anyway plus
you're getting the passive income as you
own it because you've got someone
renting it so why not buy what else are
you going to do have the money sat in
the bank or you're going to go invest in
crypto currency
getting property now just make sure that
the deal is good enough
if a good deal is a good deal then it
doesn't matter when you're buying it you
know what I'm saying yeah also like
because a lot of people are scared now
so many people are scared of buying now
there's less competitions you're
actually getting better deals now
because everyone's like oh well I'm just
going to see if it's going to dip for a
couple months whenever you call me I'm
always thinking he's either about to buy
a house yeah and he just wants to act
quickly run it past me or have some
blind spots looked at yeah or he's just
bought a house and he wants to he wants
to confirm he made the right decision
have you ever bought anything and then
you've realized actually I shouldn't
have bought that no the only time that
that's happened is when I I confirmed a
property like I think it was last year
and I hadn't had the memorandum sale for
about four months so I just rang these
stages and said look I'm not buying it
now I agree the price on what I wanted
to pay for it four months ago you've
still not sent the memorandum and sale
to my solicitor so I'm not buying it but
every decision that I made I've stuck
with because I've always done my
research before and you know property is
very slow especially what you're doing
buying houses doing them up selling them
it's taking you you know good
what have you learned in the industry
because I know for myself learning to be
patient when you I mean some of the
stuff I do and teach it's fast deal
selling rent to rent it's real quick
it's quick pound yeah and I remember
saying to you a couple of years ago yeah
all of your quick pound
should be your fashion and your your
media stuff if you want to make a quick
10 grand quick don't be trying to do
deal selling and rent them because
you've already got a business yeah yeah
you should be making as much money as
you can on your business on your regular
business and then using that money and
investing it in slow pound for real and
the thing is when I first started who I
thought I'm not like these other man
I'll make the money rapid I'll learn and
got humbled very quickly right so I mean
it does take time but also like I'm at
the point in my life and I feel like
with maturity and as experience comes as
an entrepreneur I want to move correctly
I'm not trying to move fast yeah I'm not
trying to make decisions that I've not
backed up and done all the calculations
for I just want to make sure my moves
are right like yeah in two years I've
done what three houses but look like
look how how right every move has been
really like put me in a place where now
I've got a much bigger pot to go with
now I can diversify my portfolio get
some hmos for the passive income and I
really want to get some really like us I
was going to ring you the other day
actually because I saw a bank that I
wanted to buy like that's the point I'm
at now I'm looking at you know banks
that I can build 25 apartments on so you
know in uh I'm really standing myself in
good ground in a few years I'll be doing
the much bigger deals and yeah of a
house like this Samuel you can come to
mind and call my podcast I will mate and
it's interesting as well because I think
that the smartest way to grow your
property portfolio yeah is to start with
a smaller house for sure and build up so
you started with I say small house it
wasn't a small house actually that small
no it wasn't and you still made over 100
Grand profit yeah yeah but it was just a
house yeah you know even the um
extension that you did at the back you
didn't have to get planning for that
right you've got permitted development
yeah so you didn't there wasn't a lot
that could go wrong yeah if you're doing
if you're converting a bank into 25
Apartments there's suddenly it's way
more complex there's way more to do but
because you've built up quite slowly and
steadily yeah and you've had your
foundations strong now you're at a
position where you've got the knowledge
you've got the team you've got the
know-how we can actually start doing
that comfortably yeah exactly I guess
the only alternative will be if you're
going to do big deals straight away will
be to joint venture and partner with
people that are doing it yeah you've
done this on your own all the houses
that you've bought have been solely
yours yeah yeah you've got your uh your
Instagram page I have yeah and for me as
well the Instagram page it's been really
nice to document you know some of my
journey I've not been as active on it as
I went but coming back to what we said
before I feel like so many people in my
position are just like oh this is how
I'm living
um this is what I've got this is the car
I've got but it's like how many people
are going to be there in 10 years like I
want to try and show even if people just
see that I've got a page and they're
like I need to start property some
sometime that's all I'm trying to
achieve right now whereas now that my
knowledge is really building I really
want to drop little bite-sized pockets
of information you know what I mean
because yeah I've got things that I want
to pass on opinions that I want to pass
on and like I want to encourage people
to be able to build for the future and
stuff so yeah you know that's something
that I really enjoy and something that
I'm going to be really pushing this year
so if you're watching make sure you're
following the Instagram and Tick Tock
100 and that's called Jordan's house
flip house flips oh
[Music]
no baby can you tell the story of how
you count with now because I remember us
discussing this together I don't know if
you remember well you actually came up
with the name bro yeah right yeah yeah
Samuel you came up with the name bro
because obviously I wanted to start a
page uh to document what I was doing
mainly just like it was a bit of fun
really because I was interested in
property but also I wanted to push
um a message out there that it was
possible because three years ago I was
living a lifestyle but I didn't have any
savings that first house that I bought
yeah I was stretching to buy that but
what I found is like the more that you
stretch yourself and put not too much
pressure yourself but pressing yourself
to do things that's helped me save a
hell of a lot more so any you know
motivation that I can give anyone else I
wanted to show and it was just through
document in my journey so yeah I didn't
know how I wanted to roll that out
exactly Samuel how like what do you
reckon I should call it and he was like
Jordan's house flip yeah it's got a ring
to it and I said as well if you put
house flip you can put an S at the end
yeah yeah and you know what when I put
that s on the end yeah that day was
sweet yeah I mean it goes from Jordan's
house flip where you're documenting the
flip yeah yeah so John's house flips
because I'm flipping look and the thing
is I'm always like three steps ahead
like I'm I'm busy for the next two years
my property company's got work for the
next two years now yeah I'm saying I
already know where my company is going
to be I already knew that I was going to
turn into house slits before house flips
so I think with property as well coming
back to what you said before about
patience you've got to think long term
things happen slow it takes months just
to complete like you were saying you're
waiting four months just to get the
memorandum of sale I mean typically
you're talking three months at least to
buy a house yeah then you've got the
refurb which can take six months even
more if you've got to get planning
planning takes forever planning me
I remember saying to you we were in
conversations for weeks Wednesdays I
kept messaging out as the valuation come
in yet on that first flip and you're
like
no no it does take ages and in terms of
cash flow that can prove quite difficult
you have to really plan and Advance your
I mean because you've got properties
finishing that are running over because
of X Y and Z you've got valuations that
you're waiting for so you know it's
really important to have that cushion of
money there for you for any rainy day
comes because in property That Rainy Day
always comes and you can very much go
from a powerful position to weak
position if you've not got that money
set aside for a rainy day on for when
things take a bit longer than expected
yeah so I think if there's one thing
that I want to teach everyone it's like
don't over stretch yourself and make
sure that you've backed yourself up for
when something does take a little bit
longer than expected that's what I've
learned it's interesting people
performance come to me and they've got
like a million pounds and I've got a
million pounds how do I invest it and
I'll say well why don't you start by
investing 200 Grand yeah yeah because if
you invest the whole million you're
going to be stressed and you're going to
be every day like oh what's going on was
it invested 100 Grand a couple hundred
grand or a smaller amount but then I
guess the flip side to that is board
money disappears and if you've got money
in your account just sat there you're
going to end up spending it on on dumb
stuff which is if you do stretch
yourself like you did to buy a good
property investment to do a flip then
even though you can't touch that money
it's growing it's going to come back
just keep like 10 for a rainy day and
five percent so that you can live your
everyday life what's your message then
because you're quite Keen which I think
is a great thing because sometimes
people are quite
um private about their Investments
there's a lot of people that I'm even
coaching
um that are very private they've done a
few deals but they don't want to talk
about it you're kind of the opposite
you've got your Instagram page you're
setting up your own podcast you're here
sat with me yeah like why do you do that
why do you put yourself out there open
for criticism what's the message you
want to portray I just want to show
people that like you can do it and
there's a way
like people might come across me because
of Jordan Haynes fashion and I want them
to see this isn't the only thing that I
do your soul does property and then even
if I give people the idea that they
would like to find out more about it I'd
like for that to happen yeah rather than
I'm not just trying to get rich and just
be quiet about it because like it'd be
really nice to motivate people and show
people that it's possible to do it and
if I can give you a few bite-sized
pieces of information along the way then
brilliant man I feel like I'm doing my
bit yeah I mean so I think it's super
important like why are people investing
and trying to be quiet about it and like
yeah I mean and just wanna it would feel
morally wrong for me
to have a lifestyle where I have nice
things and I do and all you see is the
nice stuff but then you don't see how
I'm sustaining that right that feels
immoral to me let me show you like how
it's done because a lot of people want
to show you that they're rich but they
don't want to show you that you got rich
and to me that's like kind of false in
it because you've got people that are
trying to get rich in their thinking to
get rich I just need to pretend that I'm
rich so they're just viewing that on
social media yeah but there's not enough
information there's not enough people in
in positions who are trying to actually
educate people on how to be financially
literate and that's why I started my
page did you grow up and well no no what
was your upbringing like no no so I just
grew up with my mum
um my mum got married when she was 18 so
I've got older brothers and sisters that
are 10 12 years older than me so when me
and my mum were living together they was
already grown up and moved out so I just
remember like 10 years old 10 years old
I remember we go to azra and almost say
right we've got 51 pounds to spend so as
we're going around We'll add it all up
and we can't go over this because we've
got bills to pay you know what I'm
saying so I learned budgeting from a
very very young age and it was it wasn't
as if we had like loads of money like
she spent money on food clothes and
child minders that I could do I mean so
there wasn't much left after that
um so one one of my biggest motivations
has been I want to give back to the
people that flipping out were there for
me when I was a kid I mean but also I
think just like when I have kids I want
to be able to be present I want to go to
Old Sports days I want to go to all the
parents meetings and to be able to do
that I need to make sure that I've got
the financial backing behind me so I can
have that flexibility because when I was
growing up my mum had to work so I mean
she didn't wasn't able to come to them
things and I'd look round thinking oh
like why is everyone else's parents here
I mean I just want I mean I want to be
able to support my family in that what's
been the biggest the proudest moment
then of your property career so far my
proudest moment was when I bought my mum
a car I retired my mom I bought my
sister a car yesterday because that's
what property enables me to do so like
with property as a business I'm not
getting emotional about it saying I'm so
happy like right this is business I
treat it like a business my proud
moments come from when I keep helping
the people around me and saying like the
smiling like the change that it puts on
their face and in the Life in it yeah
when we first met you're successful but
you're also humbled down to earth you
talk to anybody you're chatting with the
builders and you know super down to
earth and when we had our first Zoo
meeting yeah we kind of just hit it off
but it's great to see the actual fruits
of your labor you've worked super hard I
think the best way to learn is to do I
think you can only properly know
something if you're doing it however
saying that I also think it's important
to have people around you mentors people
that can guide you
um you know what what was it that made
you reach reach out to me initially why
did you kind of pick me as the go-to guy
in property yeah well I was recommended
You by live cook lives one of my good
friends obviously she's in similar
industry me and she was like you need to
speak to Samuel and bro as soon as we I
already knew about you obviously but to
have that direct recommendation was good
and like now that I had that direct
recommendation and I've met you every
single person I speak to I recommend you
to because I appreciate that I really
the guy man I really can't wait to pop
Rob Moore out as well
how's that going mate training no
naturally how did it happen oh mate me I
mean I mean I'm here to talk about you
right now okay but in a nutshell yeah me
and Rob have got a bit of a bit of
History yeah we decided to take it out
in the ring you know unreal like old
school old old school I hope you'll be
there that bro I hope you'll be there
what day is it now the first of July
yeah I'll be there yeah well mate
massive respect to what you've done
thank you on all the aspects of your
businesses and live thank you been a
real pleasure getting to know you not
just in the professional sense but also
as a mate yeah and uh look forward to
seeing you continue to absolutely take
over the world with your property Empire
my friend okay thank you bro
[Music]
thank you